klick so fast live von der gamescom hier
in köln mit stefanie heinzmann genau das
ist sie die jetzt kann ich darüber
spricht wie sie in dieses spiel
reingekommen ist mit ihrem song zum sieg
im derby 1 man hier am stand von hier
die zum just dance vor
das heißt nur damit er mut kannst du
auch so viele auf der bühne oder ja das
könnte man so sagen
aber nicht so choreografin muss es sagen
aber das tolle ist es gibt einen song
von mir auf dass tanz vier nämlich
dagegen habe ich in meiner playlist
vollmuth und das macht mich natürlich
sehr froh muss sagen ich finde als ich
liebe es zu tanzen ich muss ehrlich
gestehen ich kann nicht so wahnsinnig
gut aber ich finde halt darum geht's in
dem beben nicht es geht darum halt spaß
zu haben und das habe ich sehr viel
davon sogar okay was machst du denn dann
auf der bühne
was nämlich manchmal den dank jetzt
möchte ich meine choreografie machen
oder denkt er ich habe jetzt ist das
allerdings nicht die zeit oder ich das
passt nicht zu mir oder ich weiß ich
kann das einfach nicht nach choreografie
also ich singt und tanzt dabei was mir
gerade so was meine füße und
alles so gerade lust hat und das hat mir
oft wird halt viel spaß als ich tanz
total viel auf der bühne
aber das kann man schlecht wiedergeben
okay aber das ist das publikum findet
das klasse offensichtlich ich hoffe wir
machen keine befragung aber gibt es da
nicht manchmal wenn man so eine chance
durch geht da könnte man noch mal eine
choreo machen oder so was gut ist das
etwas wozu sagt also bei mir ist das
problem wenn mir jemand sagt machst du
das machst das was du das und das und
nach der nach den ersten 30 sekunden
muss habe ich das schon wieder vergessen
ähnlich
ja ich weiß nicht was bei uns höchstens
gibt auf der bühne ist dass ich mit
meinen mädels also meine
backgroundsängerin es wieder ein paar
songs gibt's dann so ein schritt den wir
machen aber das dann meist um einen
schritt und er wird dann weißen hut
durchgezogen weil mein mädel sieht das
natürlich total schön aus
wie kommt man jetzt also was dran
wittmann wie kommt man in so einem spiel
ein
das stimme so teuer
es macht ehrlich total bock also ich
muss sagen wenn man so ein spiel spielt
gibt da wirklich alles an songs also vom
oldtimer bis alles was gerade jetzt
aktuell ist wenn man dazwischen seinen
namen ließ ist es schon was ganz tolles
ehrlich ok dann hoffe ich dass das auch
noch bei 56 7 danke dir